you know sometimes people will ask me um
what can I do after you know is the
young people and you've spent the
weekend with them and you know what can
I do and I don't have a pat answer no I
think some people would expect me to say
join the landline campaign or join the
Nobel women's initiative campaign to
stop rape and gender violence in
conflict or join us in the new campaign
to stop killer robots but I don't you
know everybody has their own passion
even if they haven't discovered it yet
you do the best work when you are really
working on something that makes you
profoundly upset at the injustice of
whatever that issue is and if you find
people working on the issue with the
same philosophy and goal you have then
you will really become involved and be
you know a real integral part of change
if I tell you to go work on the climate
and you're not really that excited about
or worried about the climate you
probably will ultimately stop
volunteering and you'll just go back to
normal life it but if it's something
that really makes you disturbed
that's the thing you should work on
could you'll do fabulous work with
others and together you'll make an
impact you know what really bothers me
is when young women come up to me and
they say I want to be you
and my responses don't be me be better
than me no you're young and you already
understand this I was 31 years old
before I really started being a
full-time activist you're 17 you're 16
you're 15 and and you've done peace Jam
you understand you know change in the
world you can do way more than I've ever
done you should strive to be the best
you not me I've made a lot of mistakes
sally forth and make your own